an alarming post appeared in spanish on
a facebook page
in early august 2018.
it claimed spanish intelligence had
evidence of a plot to assassinate boris
johnson
hatched by remainers who didn't want the
uk to leave the european union
at the time rows over brexit were
consuming then prime minister theresa
may's government
i said i would turn i said
i said i would turn to the northern
ireland
order order the house must calm itself
zen restraint
patience you're the prime minister
mr johnson had just resigned as her
foreign secretary
but he was a top contender to replace
her in any future leadership race
no fuel needed to be added to the brexit
fire but this spanish facebook post
included a letter supposedly from
spain's foreign minister
apparently sent to a leading spanish mp
preparatory
it referred to a quote possible attack
on boris johnson
by radical brexit opponents who want to
stop him being nominated prime minister
a spanish language article based on this
letter was
quick to follow a link to that piece was
then shared on reddit
as well as other social media sites on
the surface
it was a sensational global scoop
the problem though was that it was all a
lie
[Music]
there was no remain a plot to kill boris
johnson
the letter made to appear like it was
from the then spanish foreign minister
was actually a poorly crafted hoax
and the posts that followed were all
part of an elaborate online operation
allegedly originating from russia that
was trying to spread the bogus story
it didn't succeed because the false
claim wasn't widely shared
but this is a particularly audacious
example of the kind of thing
going on across the world right now all
the time
information operations designed to make
people
think a certain way or amplify a
division
over issues like politics race even
coronavirus vaccines
imagine if enemy troops were at the door
telling you what to do
that would be a clear hostile invasion
but what if you unwittingly read
something fake online
posted by those same foreign forces just
from a computer in their own country
this disinformation then helped to
change your political views
or stirred an illogical prejudice that
turned you
against members of your own society
it would be a hostile invasion of a
different kind
one involving your mind and one that's
much harder to identify
and it's not just foreign governments
playing tricks with information
domestic political parties do it too as
do corporations and terrorist groups
it's a complex space and one of the most
powerful dimensions
of the gray zone
[Music]
my name is debra haynes i'm the foreign
affairs editor
at sky news and you're listening to my
podcast
into the gray zone which explores a
murky evolution of warfare
i'll explain the covert tactics used by
states
criminals and terrorist groups to
deceive
gain influence and at times kill
in this episode we look at how
information is used as a weapon
and visit one of the uk's best fighters
of suspected russian and chinese fake
news
ben nemo goes into battle from his
remote cottage in scotland
and if you think that sounds strange
remember
in the gray zone the front line is
everywhere
[Music]
the line between truth and lie is a
continuation
of the line between peace and war so
that the stakes here are extremely high
thomas ridd is a professor of strategic
studies at johns hopkins university in
the united states
he has a simple message the use of
information
as a weapon is nothing new but left
unchecked
there is a genuine risk of rouse online
escalating into real-world conflict
the dangers is this if we collectively
undermine the authority of the factual
then
we will risk losing our ability to
resolve
conflict peacefully here you know at
home
in our democracies we resolve conflict
by definition because we can agree on
certain facts
you know how many votes were counted in
a specific precinct or
what does science say about covid and
does this vaccine work
is climate is the climate warming as a
result of human
action or not once we lose our ability
to agree on
facts then we will have to ultimately go
after
not ideas and facts but after the people
who
hold them in other words political
violence becomes
much more likely
this warning became a reality at the
start of 2021
when supporters of donald trump stormed
the u.s capitol building in washington
dc
spurred on by a false belief he had won
the 2020 presidential election
instead of joe biden five people died in
the chaos
including a police officer
it was the first time this beacon of u.s
democracy had been breached
since british forces invaded the site
and set it on fire
in 1814 professor ridd
has written a book called active
measures the secret history
of disinformation and political warfare
the term
active measures or in russian
is used to describe an entire mode of
covert manipulation of information
people and events developed by the then
soviet union
almost a century ago but used most
prolifically
during the cold war so active measures
are
intelligence operations that are planned
designed funded and then executed in
order to
achieve a political goal in a
semi-covert way
and that can be by falsifying
information
that can be by spreading factually
correct information under false
pretenses
or more recently for example by hacking
and leaking information
with or without adding forgeries into
these
informations sometimes they're called
historically
political warfare psychological warfare
or inflammation operation or fake news
to give it a more current feel though
disinformation
is typically more sophisticated than an
outright lie
it often involves the careful crafting
of real facts and figures
but with slight distortions to twist the
truth
the key to this kind of deception which
is as true today as it was back then
is to exploit existing divisions or as
professor rid would say
unresolved contradictions within a
target society
so it turns on itself and its allies
what they mean by unresolved
contradictions is frictions
for example nascent anti-semitism in
germany in the 1960s
or unresolved racial tensions in the
united states
also in the 1960s or indeed today and
then
designing and driving a wedge into those
cracks in order to
pry them open for example to drive a
wedge between west germany
and the united states between nato
allies that kind of thing
do you have any any favorites like is
there a particularly successful
operation that springs to mind or one
that was particularly audacious
yes there are so many rather incredible
stories that history had in store there
so
let's just make one example in 1960
kgb really had a brilliant idea to take
they obviously had offices stationed in
the united states and they were seeing
in the news reports about racial
confrontations racial crimes police
brutality against african americans
lynchings in the south gruesome gruesome
events
and they thought okay this is a
potentially useful material because
african countries are currently in a
process of decolonization
and wondering should we join the soviet
bloc or should we join
the west capitalism or communism so what
they did kgb is they took
the coverage of racial crimes and police
brutality in the united states
pretended to be a fake african-american
activist organization
that wanted to show the really how
america is treating people of color
to africans produced a pamphlet 16 pages
with pictures translated into french
and english and distributed this vile
pamphlet in africa and it was
almost 100 accurate so no disinformation
other than
that they claimed it came from an
african-american organization that
didn't exist
it was extremely hard to counter for the
state department because it was
factually correct
and it wasn't just russia's then kgb
intelligence agency
or its east german equivalent the stasi
that was spinning webs of deceit
professor ridd says the cia and mi6
also dabbled in these dark arts though
he says disinformation
is more effective when used against
rather than by democracies
to put it bluntly is really hard it's
impossible to excel at democracy and
disinformation at the same time
why because this information is designed
to insidiously
undermine the authority of the factual
to undermine
trust in institutions and if you
refine the capability of doing that to
your adversary
in a semi-covert way over years
and decades and ultimately and that's
what history clearly shows
you will infect yourself this blowback
effect you will start to believe in your
own
myths and your own constructions as does
he call
it and uh so this there's the risk of
self-disinformation if you if you do it
for too long
people kind of look at this information
as if it's something new
what would you say to them oh i mean
we've seen
the level of sophistication the volume
the creativity
that were put into deception and
disinformation operations in the cold
war is
by an order of magnitude bigger than
anything that we see today the golden
age of disinformation
is in the past there's no doubt in my
mind perhaps so
but a big difference today is digital
technology
and how that helps anyone seeking to run
a disinformation campaign
professor ridd was inspired to write his
book after seeing what
he calls russia's brazen attempt to
influence the 2016
u.s presidential election with a barrage
of disinformation
critical of democratic candidate hillary
clinton and supportive
of her rival donald trump yet others
had long been warning of the threat
still posed by these soviet-era tactics
i'm always saying that there's a good
parallel in in the cold war or this
conventional confrontation
and it used to artillery attack before
real battle yeah
but now it's no need to have this
artillery attack you can brainwash
people
lines and you can then organize
selections referendums
linus linkovichus until december 2020
was the foreign minister of lithuania
it's one of the three baltic states
along with estonia and latvia we are on
the front
front lines here brainwashing is a
threat if you're demotivating people if
you're really spreading this
fake news on whatever happens if you are
organizing referendum
without informing people properly it's
also a threat
there were some referendums right yeah
there was something about brexit that
happened yeah you know so i mean
this is also very important to know that
you really sometimes you can
mislead the process you can mishandle
uh you you really looks like you are
engaging people in the
directly the democratic process and in
decision making process
but on the other hand by not informing
these people or
misleading with the fake news spoiling
you know with smart minds
you really can make big damage and this
is not artillery it's not conventional
forces something else but very
detrimental
it's hard to overstate this threat think
about it
instead of firing artillery rounds at
enemy troops before advancing
just fire off some fake news instead to
persuade them
not to bother fighting in the first
place
it also helps that an eye-catching lie
can be far more persuasive than the
truth
and that a rebuttal to whatever bogus
claim has been spread
may not be produced fast enough to
neutralize the damage
today's disinformation can be overt and
not particularly sophisticated
for example chinese officials have
suggested the coronavirus pandemic
might have originated in the united
states and that the disease was then
brought to china by visiting u.s
troops but other efforts to distort
reality
are more subtle with spy agencies hiding
behind proxy websites
compliant think tanks and sympathetic
journalists
they also use fake social media accounts
or real ones
run by people who believe the story
they're being spun
pick a divisive issue and russia is
likely to have tried to weigh in
in one way or another in the united
states it's race it's gun control
in the uk it's brexit keir giles works
for the think tank chatham house
and he wrote a handbook on russian
information warfare for the nato
military alliance
there's a reason why countries with
which russia has an argument find
themselves facing public health crises
because
of well-funded and well-organized
anti-vaccine campaigns
it is all just a measure to destabilize
and erode and subvert adversary
societies
not necessarily for any particular
political outcomes
because if you take as russia does a
zero-sum view of security then anything
that you do to weaken your adversary and
that includes the uk
in relative terms makes you stronger of
course it's not just russia allegedly
doing the meddling
china the united states iran saudi
arabia
are just some of the many countries
accused of conducting hostile
information operations online
in fact these gray zone techniques of
spin half truth and distortion
are so effective at winning arguments
that you'll recognize them being used
by most domestic political parties on
the planet without the need for
encouragement from any malign foreign
power
during the eu referendum in the uk the
leave campaign
plastered a disputed but frequently
cited claim
on the side of their brexit bus that the
uk gave 350 million pounds a week to the
european union
money which could instead be spent on
the nhs
make sure you understand you have it in
your control to determine
what this country's going to look like
the next four years is it going to
change you get four more years of these
lies
and then there's the 2020 election in
the united states
if you count the legal votes i
easily win if you count the illegal
votes
they can try to steal
the election from us donald trump
refused to concede to his rival joe
biden
after he lost the election instead
blitzing america
with unsubstantiated claims about
widespread voter fraud
it was only after an attempted
insurrection on capitol hill
one that the president himself is
accused of encouraging
that he finally backed down now congress
has certified the results
a new administration will be inaugurated
on january 20th
my focus now turns to ensuring a smooth
orderly and seamless transition of power
this moment calls for healing and
reconciliation
mr trump has a famously loose
relationship with facts
but his country is so divided that those
who support him
don't seem to mind or simply believe
what he says anyway he in turn
accuses his critics of being fake news
in many ways trump is softening the
battlefield so to speak
for a foreign actor to come in and
amplify disinformation about the
election
daniel jones used to be an investigator
for the fbi
then for the u.s senate he's now out of
government
but one of the many things he does is
run an organization called
advanced democracy which as its title
might suggest
works to help protect democracies around
the world from hostile attacks in the
gray zone
we're speaking in september 2020 we have
a president who
actively promotes conspiracy theories
you know he's seeking to sow distrust in
government in his own government um and
he's undermining
you know known facts by his own health
experts which is you've seen the impact
here in the united states in in terms of
addressing you know
cover 19. and what's the but what's the
effect of all that
well i mean the effect is exactly what
vladimir putin wants
right it is a decrease in trust in the
government
it is a decrease in the ability to us to
operate in a democratic system to find
consensus
i mean in the united states the system
is built on consensus
and that is that is how things get done
and by
pulling his supporters to an extreme and
painting his opponents
as these evil people that you can't have
anything to do with
it makes the ability to govern almost
impossible
it makes democracy look far less
appealing to to
groups out there that don't have
democracy the united states once had
while adversaries doubtlessly benefit
from any friction
within the us the uk or any other
western democracy
professor ridd warns against always
assuming a hidden foreign hand is
actively meddling
the big mistake is to think that this is
all a foreign conspiracy
if you believe that in 2016 donald trump
was only elected because of a russian
operation
well if you believe that brexit really
only happened because of some
shadowy russian intervention then what
we're really doing is we're blaming
domestic problems on foreign
interference
which is exactly what's happening in
russia in turkey in hungary
in weakening democracies or outright
autocracies
so let's not go there
[Music]
right now the safest way to bank is from
home
at lloyd's bank there's so much you can
do to manage your money online
from viewing statements to managing
direct debits to paying bills you can
speak to a mortgage advisor by video or
over the phone
and even pay in checks using our app if
you do need to visit most branches are
open 9 30 till 2 monday to friday
please wear a face covering and observe
social distancing to protect yourself
and our colleagues
lloyd's bank by your side terms and
conditions apply
to understand the threat from
disinformation better i travel to
scotland
with my producer chris to meet a
prominent online fighter of fake news
ben nemo lives and works in a remote
cottage
which we drive to by car from edinburgh
airport
so it says we're here so it says this
must be it
yeah so reckon this is about
as as contrasting as you could possibly
think
to any sort of conflict the beautiful
scottish countryside butterflies
fluttering around
birds and bushes calm serenity
and this is where this is the front line
of the gray zone
but at least we would be if we could
find it
ah there he is yay
hello how are you
i've got an amazing amazing place to
live
because of the need to social distance
we do the interview in the back garden
then starts by talking about the origins
of disinformation
long before soviet times you can make a
pretty solid case that that actually
disinformation is older than history
um if you're older than history older
than history how can anything be older
than history
if you look at the the very first known
documentary evidence of the creation of
the kingdom of egypt something like 5
000 years ago
it's a stone called the nama palette
which shows the king
nama or menace uniting the kingdom
of egypt he's portrayed as a giant who's
supported by the gods and he's smiting
his enemies he's this he's his ultimate
superman
it's carved on a on a block of stone and
you think okay
so was he actually twice as tall as
everybody else no did the egyptian gods
really smile on him no it's a piece of
it's a piece of regime propaganda
fast forward to today and anyone wanting
to exaggerate
their own greatness or their opponent's
weaknesses has the added assistance of
the internet
social media and mobile phones you can
now tell a lie
in europe and have it live streamed in
australia
so the speed is is greatly increased
your potential reach is greatly
increased because let's say on facebook
i believe they now have more than three
billion
active monthly users so you're pushing
half the population of the planet
it's on facebook in theory if you could
land your story in front of all of those
three billion people at once
and if you're convincing enough and if
it's good enough quality and if they can
actually
you know read it because there's a
language barrier then
you've reached an audience that nobody
in history would ever have reached
before
but what you have is a whole new society
that we're building online
and we don't yet have social rules and
social norms that govern it
ben learnt how to spot disinformation by
studying alleged russian tactics
i call it the 4d model which is dismiss
distort
distract and dismay and for practically
any event where
the kremlin or the russian government is
criticized you can
be sure that they will do at least one
of those four things so dismiss they
would they will insult the critics
the important words are ignore them it's
all about dismissing the critic
without looking at the evidence then
distort is if you don't have the
evidence
that supports your story you make your
own up distraction
is the classic soviet
what about you technique what about ism
so what if we're bombing ukraine you
bombed vietnam
and then dismaying tactics are you come
out with
lurid and terrifying
hypotheses if you keep on doing this
world war three will break out but the
idea is to say something so shocking and
scary that people will actually back off
and think
do we really want to do this is this
worth the risk
dismiss distort distract and dismay
in the run-up to the 2016 u.s
presidential election
ben noticed what he thought to be
suspicious content
on english language russian state
television and news websites
supportive of donald trump and critical
of hillary clinton
the same thing was happening on social
media platforms
this included posts that u.s
intelligence agencies
have since linked to an organization in
russia called the internet research
agency
it's often dubbed the troll farm because
of its alleged online trolling
at their peak they were running hundreds
of fake accounts on twitter
facebook i think they had some youtube
channels as well
um instagram and they broke down their
operation
into for example accounts that posed as
black lives matter activists
and accounts that posed as the american
far right and trump supporters and then
confederate accounts and lots of
different social groups
part of what they were doing appeared to
be just trying to stir up
trouble between different americans the
online operation
even spilled over into the real world so
famously in may 2016
they organized two simultaneous rallies
in houston texas
one of which was a protest against a an
islamic cultural center
and the other one was the
counter-protest defending the islamic
cultural center the internet research
agency organized
both events at the same time and they
told certainly the
the the opponents of the cultural center
to bring their weapons
and according to reporting from the
ground on the day they did some of the
people turned up with automatic weapons
nobody got hurt nobody got killed but
that was a case where you have the troll
farm in russia
putting armed americans on the street to
face off against each other that's
clearly putting somebody into harm's way
the kremlin has denied all allegations
of using disinformation
to meddle in the internal affairs of
other countries
as the use of social media to spread
disinformation grew
so too did demand for the talents of
investigators like ben
he began working for the us think tank
the atlantic council
and is now director of investigations at
graphica
an american company that analyzes
various forms of online data
can you just describe how you do it
you know take it into your head and into
your laptop as much as you can
a lot of the time you start off by
seeing something incongruous
and part of the art of being an
investigator is to give yourself
the time to think that's weird
why is that weird and and it it can be
so many different things that there
isn't a rule of thumb
which would say here is what you should
look out for in the sense of a
particular
turn of phrase or theme
but what you're looking for is something
which which doesn't make sense
and and for example it could be
let's say you find a a social media
account
on any platform which claims to be
called
john smith from idaho proud american
waves american flag
doesn't matter which side they're voting
for it's not a it's not a partisan thing
but you look at their posts and you
realize that john smith from idaho who
claims to be a 13th generation american
and has deeply deep roots in this
english-speaking community
can't actually use the words ah and the
appropriately
so he talks about a second world war
or he can't phrase a question
in a native idiomatic way so he talks
about what you was doing yesterday
and you start by thinking that's pretty
unusual for
somebody who would appear to be a native
english speaker those
those are errors that native speakers do
what do not make now in the case of
those two particular examples
they are errors that i have regularly
seen russian trolls making because the
russian language doesn't
distinguish between and the it doesn't
have those words
and it phrases a question differently so
that would be
a starting point where you think that
that doesn't look right and then there
would be a whole series of
checks that you would want to go through
so so is this a one-off it could just be
a typo right people do make mistakes
or is it systematic throughout his
timeline ben often works with social
media platforms like twitter and
facebook
receiving information from them on
suspicious accounts
it's how he and his team first
discovered a suspected russian campaign
that targeted the 2016 u.s elections
the 2017 french elections and the 2019
uk elections as well as brexit
then dubbed the operation secondary
infection given that we're living in the
times of covid it's worth pointing out
the name secondary infection has nothing
to do with any pandemic
any recent one instead the naming
inspiration
came from a kgb project in the 1980s
that researchers dubbed operation
infection
that disinformation campaign aimed to
spread the fake news
that the united states had created aids
as part of a military research program
the modern operation ben uncovered
posted hundreds of different lies
in multiple languages often using forged
documents
across dozens of different media
platforms
this included well-known ones like
facebook and reddit
but also far more obscure sites
i was leading the team that looked at
these accounts which are posting
all kinds of articles from around the
web which largely
the russian point of view of geopolitics
so
color revolutions are bad and instigated
by the cia russia is always a
is a benevolent actor wherever you go uh
west
the eu is chaotic ukraine is corrupt and
so we started realizing that
these couple of dozen facebook assets
were the tip of an absolutely enormous
iceberg and what we'd actually found was
an operation that was
routinely creating forged documents and
then building a series of stories about
them so for example they ran a story
that
u.s intelligence was tapping the phones
of the uk royal family
and they created a forged letter which
allegedly proved that and then they use
one account to post it
let's say on reddit and posts the one
thing and then vanishes then they create
a second account on medium
which says hmm here's something odd on
reddit i think this deserves more
investigation
and then that one goes silent and then
they find a third account maybe on
on a german website called home.com
which says wow guys you'll never believe
what the internet is now talking about
look at this scandalous thing that i've
discovered
and then they'll amplify it through uh
wordpress and blogspot and then they'll
start pushing it through facebook and
twitter
and maybe they'll do a youtube video
about it and and
this story will keep on getting bigger
and bigger and bigger but it's always
the same operation doing it from a
single-use burner account what about the
boris johnson assassin
um thank you uh i'd forgotten that that
particular gem so
they ran a story that um spanish
intelligence had discovered that
extremist remainers were plotting to
assassinate boris johnson
when he was foreign secretary in order
to stop brexit that looked like an
attempt to sow division between the two
camps on on brexit which clearly were
not divided enough already
he published a report on his findings in
june 2019
then five months later in the run-up to
the uk
general election this happened what i
have here
is something i can reveal to you
451 pages
of unredacted documents and information
jeremy corbyn the then opposition leader
appeared on camera
brandishing what he said was evidence
the government was willing to put the
uk's
coveted national health service up for
sale as part of trade talks with the
united states
quite a few open source journalists
started looking at
how did he get hold of these leaks and
then one particular journalist also
found that the same
leaks have been posted in german on
reddit and two really really small local
news sites
one of which was in berlin and the other
one was in austria
and i was digging into into this stuff
and
the combination of these two local news
sites in german with before it's news
and reddit just set all my alarm bells
going because that was the exact
combination of websites that we kept on
seeing secondary infection use
back until like may june 2019 and and so
i
i had this this this kind of
holy wow moment where i'm realizing that
the way that the leaks had originally
been posted online
exactly resembles secondary infection he
was right
and broke the story with the journalist
he mentioned jack stubbs from reuters
unlike the earlier activity based on
forge documents
this time the files linked to secondary
infection were real
and appear to have been hacked from the
email account of then-tory international
trade minister
liam fox there's still a mystery over
who or what entity was behind secondary
infection
but in july 2020 the uk government
confirmed this appeared to have been a
russian operation
so so what started off as a set of a
couple of dozen
fake facebook accounts that facebook
itself identified back in
early 2019 lit the powder trail which
ended up in
november 2019 with
us identifying this attempt at russian
interference in the uk election and then
in july 2020 the uk government
confirming
that that was an attempt at interference
but exposing disinformation operations
isn't without risk online the trolls can
get you anywhere
there are times when it gets very very
intense
yeah i got i got trolling i got various
threats online
um some of them fairly weird some of
them quite complimentary somebody
somebody in russian posted to me that he
was going to come to england in person
and hang me up next to the queen
which which i thought was kind of kind
of flattering um but you know you do get
threats against your personal safety you
know that it's hostile territory
[Music]
right now the safest way to bank is from
home
at lloyd's bank there's so much you can
do to manage your money online
from viewing statements to managing
direct debits to paying bills
you can speak to a mortgage advisor by
video or over the phone
and even pay in checks using our app if
you do need to visit most branches are
open 9 30 till 2 monday to friday
please wear a face covering and observe
social distancing to protect yourself
and our colleagues
lloyd's bank by your side terms and
conditions apply
as in 2016 the u.s presidential election
in 2020
also experienced a barrage of
disinformation and misinformation
which is still false messaging but
perhaps believed by whoever's spreading
it
u.s officials have accused iran russia
and china
of attempting to interfere in the polls
allegations they've all denied
yet the loudest voices both on and
offline
raising unsubstantiated concerns about
the vote
were much closer to home you don't
concede when there's theft
involved our country has had enough
we will not take it anymore and that's
what this is all about
this was not a close election you know i
say
sometimes jokingly but there's no joke
about it
i've been in two elections i won them
both and the second one i won much
bigger than the first okay
that was donald trump addressing his
supporters on the 6th of january
before a mob invaded the capitol
building
how do we how do we as a democracy
counter disinformation
i think you're part of the answer the
media ben wallace is the uk's defense
secretary who he first met
in episode one i don't want to be
judging jury sitting in government going
i think that's fake i don't think that
is i mean that's that's the path to
censorship
and we don't want to do that but but i
think the best people to
to put things in context are the media
or the mainstream media themselves but
is there is there a responsibility for
politicians
um to not use disinformation i mean
you know i don't get dragged into the
brexit referendum but in the brexit
referendum debate
there were on both sides um exaggerated
distorted information given out to try
to influence and to win
votes and look at president trump and
the way that
he uses fake news to make a point
and that's then exploited by our
adversaries like doesn't does that worry
you
or what can be done about that well i i
think we all have
uh an obligation to make sure that when
we engage in political debate
uh we base it on facts and we base it on
evidence and and you know people
interpret facts differently
um and we can argue over evidence
um about you know is it uh
you know what is the source of evidence
um and i think as long as you're honest
about
the source of your evidence you're using
in a debate and your facts you know
your footnote let's say and you are
prepared to engage
in in the the the reality that people
have different points of view then then
i think of course
all politicians have a responsibility in
doing that i'm not going to
give a running commentary of each
other's political debates over the last
20 years that would be there forever
um but but yes they have an obligation
but i think that's why again the
mainstream media
have a duty to question and probe and
you know be be the sort of challenger to
it
investigators like ben nemo are also
part of the answer
he was tracking online activity in the
run-up to polling day in the united
states
i asked him what he was seeing when we
met in july 2020
and there was already a lot of activity
so there's good news and there's bad
news
um the good news is that the community
of defenders the people whose job it is
to find
deceptive fake operations
online on social media is far bigger and
far more developed and is taken far more
seriously
so so what that means is if if people
want to interfere with the election
online and they try the same tactics as
2016
they're going to find it much much
harder because
the automated systems will detect a lot
the downside is that there is
so much polarization
and there are so many domestic actors in
the us
who are pushing their own narrative
and frankly right now you have the
president casting doubts
in advance on the validity of the
election that's a problem
because again you can't say donald trump
is a fake account
take him down that's really worrying so
there are
there are challenges we are facing now
that we just weren't facing to the same
extent back in 2016. because if you know
if you can
if you can prove that these are all
accounts run by a single
bunch of people in russia who are
pretending to be american
then you've got a solid case for why
they shouldn't be on platform right
they're they're
they're fakes if as far as you can tell
these are real people what do you do
about it
that's the first amendment there's
freedom of speech social media platforms
like facebook and twitter
are becoming far more active at calling
out false or misleading information
about the u.s election this includes a
massive takedown of posts
linked to cue anon a popular conspiracy
that's widely been condemned as
dangerous
though not by donald trump here's the
president
being challenged on the hoax by nbc
news's savannah guthrie
during a town hall debate ahead of the
election
let me ask you about q anon it is this
theory that uh democrats are
a satanic pedophile ring and that you
are the savior of that now can you just
once and for all state that that is
completely not true
in its entirety i know nothing about q
anon
i just talked i know very little you
told me but what you tell me doesn't
necessarily make it fact i hate to say
that
i know nothing about it i do know they
are very much
against pedophilia they fight it very
hard
president trump's own messages also
increasingly
fell foul of twitter and facebook's
crackdown on disinformation
and misinformation about the election
with warning signs
repeatedly attached to his posts
then after the breach of the u.s capitol
both companies
imposed their harshest sanction banning
mr trump from their platforms
twitter permanently facebook for at
least until
the end of his presidency the reason
given
was about fears that mr trump's language
could incite more violence
but the move immediately triggered
concerns about a threat to freedom of
speech
it underlines a fundamental challenge
facing
all democracies when the right to free
speech
enables the freedom to spread lies and
those lies
undermine the very democracy that
enshrine the right to express yourself
in the first place
also pushing back on disinformation are
western governments
but the scale of the effort is minuscule
compared with the size of the problem
and there are obvious limitations when
certain prominent politicians
as well as other domestic actors are
responsible
for much of the fake news in the first
place just this week you retweeted to
your 87 million followers a conspiracy
theory
that joe biden orchestrated to have seal
team six the navy seal two six killed to
cover up
the the fake death of bin laden now why
would you send a lion like that to your
followers
that was a retweet that was a an opinion
of somebody
and that was a retweet i'll put it out
there people can decide for themselves i
don't take a position you're not like
someone's crazy uncle who can just reach
me whatever that was a retweet
as running fake social media accounts
becomes harder
foreign states seeking to spread
disinformation
are accused of trying other avenues this
includes the hiring of genuine
journalists to write articles with a
certain slant
perhaps without the reporter knowing or
caring they're being exploited
i asked ben nemo about this when i met
him for a second time
in november 2020 to record a television
interview for this series
in case you're wondering why the
background noise sounds a bit different
we've seen operations from russia
particularly but but also from iran
trying to hire unwitting individuals so
rather than posing as an american troll
online they might pose as
a hungarian news website or
a progressive leaning website somewhere
in europe
and rather than trying to post lots of
stuff publicly
they'll contact people on professional
networks like linkedin and say hey
do you want to come and write for us
here's what we need you to write
and then a freelancer gets offered money
to write
probably gonna say yes particularly in
lockdown when so many jobs have gone
and so you start writing and then the
trolls
rather than publishing it themselves
they'll get you to write it and they'll
get you to publish it but they'll start
doing edits
they'll say well we think actually the
political tone here should be a little
bit different
why don't you add a paragraph here about
this candidate and a paragraph here
about that
and so and then they'll publish that
when it's been shaped and it's been
editorialized
the threat posed by fake news is a huge
challenge
and requires a constant mental filter
when absorbing information
and as technology advances so too does
the ability
to manipulate people's minds artificial
intelligence
can create images and video known as
deep fakes
of say politicians or events that look
convincingly real
even though they're not take this clip
that appears to show
former president barack obama calling
his successor donald trump
the total and complete [ __ ] that deep
fake was created
to show how the technology works you see
i would never say these things
at least not in a public address then
there's the use of data
to target messages at specific
individuals based on an assessment of
personal information
like social media presence browsing
history and credit score
at the moment we're seeing an increasing
invasion of our mental autonomy
online as technology increasingly
allows those posting online to influence
how we think without us necessarily
knowing about
it kate jones is a former foreign office
lawyer
who now works as director of oxford
university's diplomatic studies program
she's worried about how social media
giants like twitter and facebook
are being left to try to manage what's
effectively an information war
without any kind of international rules
of engagement
the question then is where do we draw
the line
between legitimate influence on the one
hand and illegitimate
manipulation on the other how
comfortable are you
at the moment looking at the information
space and
seeing that it's being really left up to
individual
companies like the social media
platforms to decide
what is and isn't acceptable content
i am really uncomfortable with the
current position
we hear from tech experts that the
technology is developing
all the time the manipulation is
becoming more and more sophisticated
and that it is cropping up in more and
more countries
electoral and political systems at the
same time
states governments aren't yet really
doing very much about it
at all and we have a handful of social
media platforms
who are ex who are doing their best to
try and combat it
but are having to set their own rules of
the road
and are constantly having to be
responsive to what's happening
rather than having clear parameters in
advance about what's acceptable
the situation urgently needs to change
otherwise
frankly our democracies are at threat
a senior western diplomat once asked me
whether i thought the truth matters
anymore
given the power an alluring lie has to
influence people
my answer was of course truth matters
perhaps that sounds naive but as a
journalist
the truth is like the solid ground
beneath my feet
take truth away and the world suddenly
becomes a lot less stable
that said like anything in the gray zone
the truth can also be weaponized
the hacking and leaking of genuine facts
as happened with the u.s uk trade
documents
in the run-up to the 2019 uk election
is a powerful weapon it can be used to
influence mines
and damage reputations i even found
myself
caught up in the fallout of a suspected
russian hacker leak
greetings we are the anonymous charity
also known as the collective
we have obtained a large number of
documents relating to the activities of
the integrity initiative project
but that's next time as we continue into
the gray zone
into the gray zone is a sky news podcast
it was edited and produced by chris
scott
with production support from sophia
mcbride and victoria seabrook
and narrated by me debra haynes
additional voice provided by cayetano
delgado
the head of sky news radio is dave
terrace
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts